when people get married what do they do
with their finances how do they just
suddenly combine everything yes and like
split everything right down the middle
no you combine everything there's no
middle the preacher didn't say and now
you're a joint venture he said and now
you're one so what if one person makes
more than the other like you're not a
partnership you're a marriage let me
give you an example my wife has not had
an earned income for 30 years she stayed
home with our children I do not have an
income we have an income it's just as
much hers as it is mine spiritually
morally and by the way legally and so
it's it's our income and she and I sit
down where she to earn an income it
would be in the P put in a pile with
mine and I don't get more votes if I
make more money we both have a vote we
both are going to sit down together we
love each other we are going to decide
about our you're hearing my pronouns
here